- I'm gonna need you to
let me know at some point
where you got that
sweater 'cause I want it.
- Well, I'll tell you a
story. I'll tell you story.
It's funny 'cause your peeps
backstage even gave me love
for this little.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So this is the first time
I broke it outta the closet
and I've had it a little over a year.
So People Magazine came to my house
and did like this little "In
the Life of Shemar Moore."
And I just bought a new
house, and it was decorated,
and put it all together.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so they hired a
stylist to jazz me up,
to have me looking a
certain, you know, get-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Get me pimping
for the photo shoot.
- [Kelly] Did they bring that?
- And so they brought
all these groovy clothes.
And so everybody in my
camp, my homies and all.
They're like, "Nah, that sweater ain't it.
That sweater ain't it."
- [Kelly] That sweater is it.
- And I used it in the photo shoot
and I was like, "There's
something about it."
- Also like, like the hippest
Mr. Roger's vibe ever.
- There you go. There you go.
- [Kelly] I'm into it.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Like you walked out
and I was like, "I will
own that at some point.
I'm gonna find it."
- I woke up this morning and you know,
I woke up this morning. I was like,
"Okay, what am I gonna wear
for Kelly?" I was like,
"Alright. I got this."
- [Kelly] Nice choice.
- "I got this. I got this, I got this."
And then I looked up on the
shelf and I saw these shoes
and they still had the price tag on them.
- You're like, "I should
probably wear those."
- So I started, so I said,
"Okay, these jeans contrast."
I picked the shoes. I was like,
"Okay, what goes with the shoes?"
And I was like, in my closet,
I going, "No, no, no, no.
Okay. I'm gonna rock
the fedora. What else?"
And then the sweater was
just calling my name,
and I was like, "You know
what? Today's the day."
- [Kelly] I love this sweater.
(audience cheering)
It's a hit. Do you enjoy
like clothes and all that?
Do you enjoy fashion?
'Cause every time I see you,
you always look so sharp.
- Well thank you. I mean, I'm
not, I'm not Mr. Fashion Guy.
I just, I just kind of, I like shopping.
I mean, but I'll shop
twice a year, you know?
Like I'll just, I'll
just go big twice a year.
- [Kelly] That's me.
- And I got, and I got my
little stores that I like.
Yeah. And I'll go in and
go, "Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Okay. I'm good for six months."
I don't know if you're
allowed to say names.
I go to G-Star. I get all my jeans.
- Yeah. You like what you like.
- Up on Sunset Boulevard,
this place called H. Lorenzo.
It's got a kind of European thing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- With their style.
I go there. I go to the
GAP to get t-shirts.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- I'm a Calvin Klein underwear
dude. You know, like it's-
- I'm a Calvin Klein girl.
- [Shemar] There you go.
- Yeah.
We have things in common.
They're just comfortable is the thing.
And I like the band.